protesters around the country are
blocking roads to demand a ceasefire in
Gaza demonstrators have caused massive
traffic jams tried to cut off access to
the airport and kept thousands of people
from going about their daily lives I
have a daughter in Brooklyn you're
disrupting traffic idiots it's an
interesting approach when considering
the goal of a protest is to change
hearts and Minds you may not be shocked
to hear it's not working a record high
number of people now say the US isn't
doing enough to help Israel according to
a recent Gallup poll these protests
aren't exclusive to the Israel Palestine
debate in 2022 activist side DC blocked
a highway to demand Biden declare a
climate emergency while they didn't
accomplish that they may have cost a man
his parole since they stood in the way
of him getting to work on time one Lan
I'm asking one Lan to jail for what you
do this woman went into labor during a
San Francisco block a protest in 2014
and not long ago this 82-year-old was
caught in a blockade protest while her
brother tried to get her to the
emergency room protests aren't meant to
be convenient but they are meant to
persuade so if one of these protests
caus you to have a medical emergency or
miss your flight would that change your
mind